[Music]
guys the overwatch League may only have
one season to its name so far but it's
already provided us with some incredible
caster calls from the hype
- hilarious wordplay time who rejects
transcendence he's gonna stay the same
forever on that row dog two moments so
intense the casters physically buckled
under the pressure it's safe to say that
a lot of these calls will go down as
truly iconic in the history of pro
overwatch and if you want to be as
iconic as I am now well you can pick up
this t-shirt and plenty more at the
score eSports new online merged
apartment a truly iconic link will be
pinned in the comments section below now
without further ado guys let's get on
with it with a top ten caster calls from
overwatch League season one kicking off
our list at number ten is the moment
when carpe effectively became the first
player in the overwatch league to go
absolutely ham on Widowmaker even
casters Doha and Monte Cristo seemed as
if they were taken off-guard by car pays
lethal skills however and does die
somehow carpe gets the counter Saipan
the baby they dock freeze my bow the
deck goes down carpe totally going wild
on this Widowmaker right now oh do you
look like it looked like San Francisco
it's such a good opportunity but Hart
Bay is just going again all of them
not that one oh you can't finish it off
defense matrix there to try and help oh
there we go
baby Bay the Menace has finally been
dealt with sometimes a play is so
absurdly sick that the only sentiment a
caster can muster is rage coming in at
number nine is uber becoming audibly
upset with Tuvok as the player takes out
an airborne Farah with Ganges deflect
abilities
similar skip make totemic but that's
disgusting straight at libero from long
range
uber is revered not only for his
incredible casting but for these
shamelessness of his wordplay which is
why this one comes in at number eight on
our list when confronted with the
Houston outlaws cheesy use of a shield
protected bastion turret the
Philadelphia fusion makes such an
improbable turn that uber couldn't help
but dish out a juicy at the ring they
seen the cheese now they're bringing
mistake during the London Spitfire stage
one final against the New York Excelsior
profit guided ad winning junk rat
ultimate into the back of Arc's mercy
and coming in at number 7 is doe as
glorious effort to add profits hundred
thousand dollar ripped higher to eSports
already existing group of monetized
Ultimates the number six entry on our
list reminds us that overwatch is a game
in which the line between carry and
support is especially fuzzy watch and
listen as uber tries to keep Neptuno in
check as the fusion players battle mercy
leverages a two-man revival into a
triple kill redefining what it means to
swoop in for the rescue no gets the kill
on Jake while he was channeling that
ability the caduceus blasts the pain
lock quite well and now over the points
a bit of a dosey doe at the houston our
lord
come out even in front for now I'm gonna
be the Valkyrie news leaks is gonna be
very careful make sure it gets another
kill in that but the murder battle
Bessie what is going on that you know
your fob
will it be the difference though remains
to be seen couple big Hilson Atmos a big
part of being in the overwatch League is
being a God with projectile heroes and
coming in at number 5 we have Hagel poon
who puts on his any on a snipe show
against the Boston uprising even a
caster as composed and calculated as
uber couldn't help but shout random
phrases as the spiritual support held
his ground stop get away from property
sitting on top of that mini health pack
that's unbelievable
one man army disgusting different what
is this perspective
oh my god throwing shades man oh my god
that is filthy stuff just the headshot
it's such a satisfying noise so you're
in the bus that I've never seen that
I've never seen that before
[Applause]
coming in at number four we have the
call that followed the infamous 4k that
pine scored against the London Spitfire
in junker town Noah and Monte Cristo
can't even watch the replay of Pines
final flick shot without entering a
state of utter disbelief
the other commission steps up to the
plane and hits a grand slam and that's
what you get with pine Noah he flanks
around the backside of the London
formation as you're about to see with
the emphasize and nailed the shots not
many widow-makers would go for this play
I would just absolutely nails it here
even the third spot on our list sees the
return of car pays already legendary
Widowmaker watch as the South Korean
assassin squeezes off some of the
nastiest head shots you'll ever see in
such quick succession that even the rap
God himself struggles to keep his
composure both supports are called
together that's what they need a base
[Music]
[Applause]
what the hell is that if there's
anything to learn from our runner-up
it's that nicknames can only ever be
earned during the New York Excelsior
stage one match against the Houston
outlaws big boss pine conducted a master
class in McCree causing Doha to bellow
Pines now notorious nickname with such
fervor that it solidified the size of
the South Korean superstars authority
once and for all rolling early Cho neck
does go down a Reds comes in from NY
excel and here comes mine gets one gets
two looking for a bit more gets another
one are you kidding me this guy is gonna
single-handedly change the point back
over that started so well for Houston -
they forced the early rez on to Joe Knox
taking the top spot on our list is an
epic yet innocuous line that won't soon
be forgotten during the LA gladiators
first playoff match against the Spitfire
uber made an observation about sure fors
exhilarating decision to chill in base
which has since come to be regarded as
one of the greatest strategic maneuvers
in the games competitive history where
are you going oh this is so not come
close to hitting it small so he's
waiting key we can sort of walk now what
I'll try to do is I think he's gonna
either he's gonna either switch to
Widowmaker
i'ma call this the merry-go-round
because that makes me laugh a sweet
happy in short boys winters to the
Widowmaker just the rat five clothes are
drums down and at the day the shooting
range for Lane Roberts a Canadian
superstar unloads on a Spitfire and then
completely smashed
[Applause]
the best-laid plans file but not this
one big flank from the gladiators in a
let loose the widow at just the right
time well guys that's our list for this
week now did we miss out on your
favorite overwatch League season one
caster call well let us know in the
comments below leave a like and don't
forget to sub to the channel to see you
next week thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button